analizar una semana en la que el fútbol
femenino ha tenido mucha actividad
tenemos con nosotros a Estefanía Montero
periodista especializada bienvenido
Estefanía Gracias por estar con nosotros
Hola Omar buenas noches y por supuesto
hablemos de fútbol femenino que
indudablemente está dando muchas
noticias esta semana Cómo se ven las
perspectivas volviendo a este repechaje
donde tenemos a Paraguay Panamá
disputando un cupo y por otra parte
chile contra Haití otro Cómo se ven las
perspectivas para estos tres equipos
serán dos llaves bastante complicadas
para los suramericanos sobre todo por
dos razones en el lado de Paraguay
enfrentará a un Panamá que viene de
ganar relativamente tranquilo su partido
de la primera ronda de este de este
torneo de repechaje mientras que
Paraguay ha hecho un esfuerzo físico
bastante importante y que por ahí puede
costar esos 120 minutos en temperaturas
también bastante altas donde se juega en
ese momento el repechaje miremos la otra
llave Chile Chile enfrentará un Haití se
volvió a senegal en esa primera ronda en
esa primera llave pero chile tiene unos
temas y es que viene de perder también
con Argentina cuatro a cero en un
amistoso previo a a este torneo No se ve
bien chile desde incluso la Copa América
femenina chile ha mostrado ciertas
falencias sobre todo desde la parte
técnica hay preocupación también en el
entorno chileno tiene a una de las
figuras nominada premio de beza
cristiana que es una de las mejores
arqueras del mundo por supuesto queremos
ver a Chile en el mundial que repita ese
mundial que hace cuatro años estuvo
queremos ver también por supuesto a
Paraguay en su primera aparición por lo
que representa a nivel Social para las
paraguayas y por el lado de Panamá Creo
yo que puede tener una cierta ventajas
del punto físico frente a las paraguayas
Cómo se ven
particularmente el tema de las
paraguayas preocupa porque les ha tocado
resolver en el último momento no en este
partido reciente contra china taipei les
tocó sobre la y ayudar de alguna manera
por por la fortuna no con el tema de de
los penales fallados por la chinas
indudablemente humano el partido fue
frenético yo lo vi desde el principio
Paraguay manejó Yo creo que el 90% de la
posesión de de este de este juego pero
china taipei jugó a esperar a esperar
los errores y eso pasó hubo dos errores
y y Paraguay estuvo al borde de la
eliminación casi siempre yo creo que en
los en los ciento veinte minutos jugados
Paraguay es su valor de la eliminación
pero como dicen en el fútbol hay cosas
que son de suerte y Paraguay la acompañó
la suerte hubo cambios también en el
segundo tiempo reglamentario los noventa
minutos la entrada de Fanny ga auto
ayudó mucho en el momento sobre todo de
la definición en el ataque que por ahí
Paraguay no estuvo no estuvo fino
esta semana hemos visto muchísima acción
en lo que amistoso se refiere vemos a
Colombia en la copa revelations a
Uruguay en el torneo de Francia también
ha estado Brasil en la copa chibilips
qué balance se puede hacer
particularmente de los latinoamericanos
que han estado empeñados en estos
eventos internacionales
Sí Omar Colombia está en la revelation
stop que se está jugando en México en
este momento ha empatado frente a Costa
Rica y ganó Un gol por cero frente a
Nigeria Colombia sigue Ajustando piezas
no se ha visto con ese juego que le
vimos contundente en la Copa América
linda Caicedo marcó un gol sigue siendo
importante en el ataque Tuvo una baja
para este torneo Colombia que fue la
lesión de Lazy Santos la número diez de
Colombia que presentó un tema muscular y
se quedó en su equipo en su Club el
Atlético de Madrid pero no he encontrado
todavía el técnico Nelson abadía ese
equipo que lee la tranquilidad a
Colombia sobre todo en el tema defensivo
en el juego aéreo pasemos ahora la
chibilift que se está jugando en Estados
Unidos
Brasil un triunfo una derrota sigue
siendo para Brasil un un poco de de
sazón y de alegría pero también de
preocupación Yo creo que la ahora Pía
sondaje como lo ha mencionado como lo
mencioné la Copa América está tranquila
a nivel suramericano pero ya sabe que a
nivel mundial Brasil necesita mucho más
el regreso de Marta importantísimo eh
una jugadora espectacular de las mejores
del mundo de las más ganadoras en la era
de Brasil y por supuesto va a ser Va a
ser muy importante en el lado de Uruguay
importantísimo los pasos que está dando
el fútbol uruguayo femenino su primer
sus primeros tandas amistosas a nivel
europeo se ha enfrentado a Francia que
cayó goleado evidentemente pero es
importante el progreso a nivel femenino
también eh perdió en su primer partido
pero Sigue avanzando el fútbol
suramericano de cara lo que va a ser
este año mundialista y esperemos a ver
que se resuelve también en este
repechaje para ya determinar Quiénes son
los equipos que van a ir al